et karim sader en direct dans ce gîte et
politologue et consultant spécialiste du
moyen-orient
bonjour carême c'est à dire merci de
répondre à nos questions le procès par
contumace de vin saoudien s'est donc
ouvert tout à l'heure à istanbul quelle
caisse de résonance à ce procès à
l'international vis-à-vis de l'arabie
saoudite et du prince héritier mohammed
bin salman
il vient à nouveau ravivé ce dossier qui
avait suscité l'émoi
je rappelle quand même bien un peu moins
de deux ans en octobre 2018 avec ces
détails totalement sordide et la manière
dont les amener ça retient à l'époque
avait essayé de dans un premier temps
nier leur implication dans l'assassinât
du malheur aux journalistes avant d'être
se retrouver contraint d'avouer les
faits c'est un dossier extrêmement
embarrassant que qui revient sur le
devant de la scène avec effectivement
donc l'image de l'arabie saoudite qui a
écorné
et puis quelque part aussi les rivalités
régionales qui a derrière puisque ce
procès n'a pas lieu n'importe où il a
lieu en turquie qui est qu'il ait
d'autre que la puissance rivale sur
l'échiquier régional sunnites avec
l'arabie saoudite dont care on sait que
ankara et des ryads entretiennent des
relations extrêmement tendues et c'est
pas moyen donc aujourd'hui pour la
publie quelque part eux comment
dirais-je en tout cas marquer des points
et discrédit nous décrédibiliser
discréditer à nouveau son rival sunnite
dans la région qui est le royaume
wahhabite arabie saoudite avec à sa tête
évidemment hamad bin salman dont la
responsabilité est clairement pointée du
doigt dans cette affaire où on l enquête
justement deux ans après le meurtre
jamal khashoggi à l'image que ce procès
c'est quelque chose de d'abord
symbolique les principaux prévenus ils
n'assisteront pas donc à ce procès on
sait très bien qu'ils sont protégés ou
dire ils ont été blanchis par le
l'arabie saoudite qui a refusé de les
extrader certains responsables ça a été
cité dans votre récapitulatif comme le
général ahmad l'assiette du
renseignement ou encore le conseiller du
prince héritier qui est pardon non qui
ont été blanchis carrément donc il faut
pas attendre grand chose si ce n'est que
encore une fois un bras de fer un
symbolique et je veux qu'ils que va
utiliser entre un moyen en tout cas pour
la turquie de décrédibiliser son rival
trop attendre grand chose
je pense que la seule énigme qui demeure
et sais pas si on aura la réponse ce
sont la caisse et la question des restes
du malheureux journaliste gay qu'est-il
advenu mais sinon il faut pas attendre
grand chose de ce procès un haut niveau
je parle du plan judiciaire au niveau
justice ne peut pas forcément attendre
grand chose vous vous dites mais au
niveau international au niveau des
relations diplomatiques entre les pays
entre donc la turquie et l'arabie
saoudite vous en avez parlé mais avec
par exemple les états unis qui sont
immiscés dans ce dossier également
quelles conséquences au niveau de la
diplomatie mondiale
c'est important effectivement des deux
rivaux le souligner parce que c'était
depuis déduit un dossier embarrassant
pour tous les alliés de l'arabie
saoudite on sait que beaucoup de
puissances occidentales à commencer par
les états unis mais également en france
au sein de l'union européenne
toutes ces puissances la ti dental sont
pas liés par des intérêts communs avec
l'arabie saoudite et parfois au risque
de mettre sous le tapis
certaines pratiques comme le niveau déjà
démocratique mais également comme cette
malheureuse affaire qui a eu lieu donc
on voit bien que la réelle politique a
pris le dessus dans les relations entre
l'occident et l'arabie saoudite sur ce
que cette affaire a embarrassé les
dirigeants parce qu'elle a élu l'opinion
publique internationale et la voilà de
nouveau
justement sous les alizés merci merci à
mme sader pour cet éclairage je rappelle
que vous êtes un politologue et
consultant spécialiste du moyen-orient